un paso firme en Cuba hacia un acuerdo
definitivo así se desarrolló el cierre
del Tercer ciclo de negociaciones de paz
entre el gobierno colombiano y el grupo
guerrillero en activo más grande del
país el eln en el encuentro se firmaron
varios lineamientos para facilitar el
diálogo entre ellos un cese al fuego que
comenzará el 3 de agosto y se extenderá
por 180 días el más largo pactado hasta
ahora rebajar la intensidad del
conflicto para que en Colombia
haya un mejor clima para la
participación de la sociedad en este
proceso de paz ese consideramos que es
de los aportes importantes de los
acuerdos que hemos suscrito acá el alto
el fuego se desarrollará bajo la ejida
de varios mecanismos de monitoreo la ONU
el gobierno la Iglesia Católica y
contará con un proceso pedagógico previo
para discutir las prohibiciones que se
harán efectivas que este firma de estos
acuerdos
parciales hoy que los llevan a ustedes a
un cese al fuego a un punto que nunca
habían experimentado en los diálogos
a un cese al fuego que sigue con una
promesa el 25 de mayo en mayo del 2025
cesa definitivamente la guerra de
décadas entre el eln y el estado de
Colombia
Naciones Unidas reaccionó el acuerdo de
ses el fuego la ONU lo calificó como un
paso importante que da Esperanza al
pueblo colombiano la cuarta Ronda de
diálogos tendrá lugar en Venezuela entre
el 14 de agosto y el 4 de septiembre